on va plus loin avec aujourd'hui
exceptionnellement n'ont pas deux mais
une invitée ma consœur Claude guibalgor
portait à France Inter bonjour Claude
bonjour de retour des États-Unis vous
avez couvert à la campagne des mitormes
les élections de mi-mandat dont on
attend toujours de connaître les
résultats définitifs pour l'heure les
démocrates gardent le contrôle du Sénat
le siège qui reste attribué en Géorgie
le mois prochain ne changera pas le
rapport de force en revanche chacun des
deux parties n'a encore pour l'heure pas
de majorité à la chambre basse celle des
représentants même si les républicains
ne sont plus qu'à un siège d'après la
projection de notre partenaire la
société de presse c'est connaissant cet
état des forces que Donald Trump va
prendre la parole dans les prochaines
heures depuis son complexe de Mara Lago
en Floride pour avait-il prévenu à une
très grosse annonce une sortie qui
semble désormais totalement à
contretemps tant la Floride justement
apporter en triomphe son rival chez les
républicains Rome De Santis réélu
gouverneur par un raz-de-marée qui
s'impose comme le prétendant le plus
sérieux désormais à la candidature
républicaine pour 2024
Floride où vous vous êtes rendu
justement Claude pour sonder le cœur des
électeurs républicains on va écouter
l'extrait d'un de votre reportage pour
France Inter
on a plus le droit d'évoquer devant des
élèves de maternelle ou de primaire quoi
que ce soit qui est un lien avec
l'identité de genre
le courant la menace ultime pour homme
de Santis qui en a fait l'objet d'une
loi spécifique run De Santis appuyé par
les mom's for Liberty un puissant lobby
de parents qui dénonce les dangers du
système éducatif à travers les
États-Unis l'organisation conservatrice
née en Floride compte désormais plus de
100 000 adhérents en deux ans
d'existence
on est aussi très fier d'être contre les
vaccins contre les certifications de
vaccination ou quelconque obligation
l'été dernier run the Santi Samy la
Floride à la une en créant une polémique
nationale avec les migrants il a
également réduit les délais d'avortement
à 15 semaines sans exception pour les
viols et l'inceste sa gestion des suites
du terrible ouragan ayant le mois
dernier lui a permis de montrer ses
capacités managériales plus présentable
que Donald Trump
est devenu en quelques mois à rivals
dangereux pour l'ancien président qui
hier tenait un meeting à Miami où il ne
l'a pas invité mais sur le parking se
termine son meeting des drapeaux
flottent au vent sur l'un une phrase
mais que ma mère Florida fait que
l'Amérique devienne comme la Floride
voilà c'est votre voix je précise qu'on
entend évidemment sur ces images Claude
c'est pour conjurer la candidature de 26
que Trump s'apprête à annoncer la sienne
dans les prochaines heures avant avant
que Run De Santis soit réélu très très
massivement Donald Trump avait fait
monter la tension de toute façon il voit
arriver Ron des Santis qui avait été élu
grâce à son soutien mais élu de peu en
Floride et qui effectivement alors je
pouvais que le constater sur place et
d'une popularité énorme et a réussi en
Floride à faire basculer la fluidité
d'un état pivot en un état qui
aujourd'hui très rouge et qui a trouvé
dans runes des Santis l'alternative
acceptable en fait à Donald Trump vous
qui avez rencontré en foyer nombreux
électeurs républicains il voteraient
pour qui eux en cas de primaire de santé
Trump alors généralement ce qui sort
c'est dessiner et puis il y a un
deuxième il y a le deuxième effet qui en
fait ça serait pas mal qui reste en
Floride donc si jamais Trump se présente
bon d'accord mais ce que dit ce tous
c'est que les meilleurs chances pour le
parti républicain ce serait de sentis
parce que Donald Trump a pu plusieurs
handicaps désormais bon d'une part son
âge ensuite c'est les démêler
judiciaires qui vont continuer à
alimenter un petit peu le débat dans les
mois qui viennent et puis enfin run des
Santis comme je disais et plus
présentable plus acceptable que Donald
Trump c'est un Donald Trump si vous
voulez sans les outrances verbales le
discours est aussi radical aussi
extrémiste extrêmement conservateur mais
sur la forme c'est beaucoup plus
acceptable on pouvait certains reprocher
à Donald Trump un certain manque
d'empathie avec les gens en rhum des
Santis si c'est très bien y faire et
puis il a montré là pendant pendant
l'ouragan ayan comment il a il a géré ça
et donc voilà il a il a réussi à donner
aux parties républicain quelque part le
visage acceptable d'un conservatisme
très fort et que les républicains
n'avaient pas jusqu'à leur trouver c'est
Donald Trump centre mais c'est vrai que
lorsqu'on écoute le discours les idées
là ils se vantait effectivement dans le
ce qu'on vient d'entendre d'être même
contre les vaccins pas seulement contre
l'obligation vaccinale mais même contre
les vaccins lorsqu'on entend le discours
sur les écoles et sur la question des
juges du genre on se dit sont quand même
des idées qui pourraient sembler
extrêmement marginales et qui par sa
personnalité sont en train de devenir
mainstream comme on dit aux États-Unis
absolument rien en fait ce que Run des
senti ça fait depuis plusieurs années
c'est que il se prépare très clairement
pour la Maison Blanche même si il a un
petit peu relativisé ses propos modéré
ses propos récemment mais ce qu'il a
fait runes des senti c'est regarder ce
qui faisait en gros l'actualité ou le
buzz quelque part aux États-Unis pour le
transposer en Floride et voir ce que ça
pouvait donner et donc ce qu'il a
pendant le covid c'était la Floride en
état libre pas de pas de masque
interdiction même de mettre des masques
dans les écoles confinement limité à son
maximum résultat les Floridiens étaient
ravis et beaucoup d'Américains qui
étaient contre les confinements dans
leur propre état sont venus ce sont des
placer en Floride qui est un état de
toute façon extrêmement attractif
beaucoup de gens ont une résidence
secondaire ou viennent prendre leur
retraite plus en plein air donc
peut-être un bilan humain aussi moins
long
mais il est pas plus lourd que celui de
New York qui avait imposé des normes
beaucoup plus drastiques
là-dessus à jouer à jouer très gros puis
il a vu arriver tout le débat national
autour de l'idéologie wok et là-dessus
il a bien compris que c'était comme ça
qu'il allait pouvoir gagner une partie
de l'électorat qui manquait aux
républicains en Floride qui était
l'électorale latino était plus
traditionnellement démocrate mais là il
s'est adressé aux parents et aux mères
latinat pour le coup en jouant sur
l'aspect ultra conservateur religieux
idéologique avec ce cette idéologie walk
qui fait très très peur le wokisme mais
aussi une révision aussi de l'histoire
américaine
impulsée par il est aidé la dent dans
par un lobby ultra conservateur qui
s'appelle l'héritage fondation qui est
notamment contre la séparation de
l'Église et de l'État et ils sont en
train de réécrire les manuels scolaires
de Floride avec eux jusqu'à envoyer des
migrants à martas Vignal qui est un peu
l'île de ré-américaine c'est jubilatoire
ça pour une partie de la droite
américaine similatoire pour une partie
de la droite américaine et une certaine
partie
de démocrate déçu qui en ont marre des
élites et en faisant cela Ron des Santis
a déplacé la question migratoire qu'on
voyait sur les frontières en disant
voyons voir vous a mis démocrate
richissime qu'est-ce que vous allez
faire de ces migrants il les a envoyés
donc sur l'île de martheus Magnard et
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont
décrété l'état d'urgence donc panique à
bord pour quelques quelques dizaines de
migrants et donc une autoroute pour un
des Santis pour dire vous voyez bon le
problème est pas chez nous tous ces
électeurs démocrates qui faisaient dans
le passé de la Floride d'un swing state
ils sont passés où et bien ces électeurs
démocrates alors pour certains ils se
sont ils ont arrêté de s'affilier à des
parties ce qui est possible en Floride
où on peut être
non partisans en fait et puis beaucoup
donc on switché vers les républicains
pour cette raison de l'éducation parce
que c'est vraiment quelque chose sur
lequel run De Santis a misé ce sont les
parents la famille
l'esprit de nations et ils ont aussi
misé donc sur sur le sur le covid c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui les a marqué
on ne les senti ça aussi chez des
mesures électeurs à listes très fortes
en baissant les taxes sur les sens au
maximum les trois mois avant l'élection
de façon à montrer que grâce à lui grâce
à lui les choses les choses pouvaient
aller et puis il y a enfin le fait que
beaucoup n'ont pas pardonné aux
démocrates d'avoir abandonné certaines
choses comme ou d'avoir participé à des
à des initiatives comme celle de defend
the police c'est-à-dire d'enlever de
couper dans les budgets de la police
pour les redistribuer au niveau des
services sociaux alors que la
criminalité est un des gros thèmes de
cette campagne il n'y a pas un coussin
des électeurs parmi les cadres du parti
républicains aujourd'hui les langues se
délit écoutez Mike Pen s'il fut
vice-président de Donald Trump pour
avoir certifié les résultats l'élection
présidentielle de 2020 contre les
injonctions de Trump il s'est vu menacer
d'être pendu à une corde par les
supporters déchaînés de l'ancien
président lors de l'assaut du Capitole
du 6 janvier de l'année dernière il est
revenu pour la première fois sur cet
épisode c'était dimanche soir sur la
chaîne NBC écouter
les mots du président et ses actes ont
été imprudents
les mots du président ont mis en danger
pour moi ma famille et tout se
présentent au Capitole je n'ai pas eu
peur
mais j'ai ressenti beaucoup
d'indignations après ce que j'ai vu
je dois vous dire en ce qui concerne le
personnel de la Maison Blanche ou même
la responsabilité du président sur cette
journée
je laisse ça au peuple américain
pensez-vous que Donald Trump puisse
redevenir président
mais je pense qu'on aura de meilleures
solutions à l'avenir
pourquoi avoir attendu aujourd'hui pour
en parler Claudie était nombreux
pourtant ces républicains à être choqués
du déni démocratie manifestée par Trump
le 6 janvier 2021 et puis tout sont
rentrés dans le rang on attend que la
vague rouge n'est pas lieu en fait il
semble que les républicains ont compris
que Donald Trump n'étaient plus le
faiseur de roi qu'il pouvait être et qui
pouvait un petit peu se débarrasser de
lui à ce titre que Mike pence qui a
effectivement été menacé de mort et
attendu aussi longtemps pour pouvoir
pour s'exprimer s'exprimer en ces termes
montre bien que ça y est on a lâché le
cheval Trump parce que comme le disait
la très conservatrice Fox News qui a
quand même contribué très largement à la
popularité de Donald Trump
c'est un perdant c'est vrai
le terme de loser appliqué à Donald
Trump le soir même de ces élections de
meeters par par Fox News était à ce
titre extrêmement révélateur c'est la
surprise de voir finalement deux
Américains à part égale sans
raz-de-marée républicain qui inquiète
dans le camp du dans le camp Président
si enfin dans le camp de l'ancien
président est-ce qu'on n'avait pas placé
la barre trop chez les républicains en
tout cas les républicains avaient été
partagé n'avait pas fait ce ce choix là
il y avait laissé en quelque sorte aussi
Donald Trump qui avait la main sur le
parti placé placé ses candidats ce qu'on
a vu c'est que les candidats placés par
Donald Trump n'étaient pas ceux qui
étaient réélu ou élus à l'exception par
exemple de jellyvens dans l'Ohio mais
les candidats Trump ou encore car il a
été au poste de gouverneur n'a pas été
élu ce sont les républicains sortants
qui ont eux
étaient élus donc vous savez que le
Parti démocrate a notamment contribué à
financer les candidats placés par Donald
Trump pour les primaires républicaines
de façon voter pour les Trump en disant
ils sont inéligibles au final de façon à
mettre des candidats qui allaient être
trop clivant pour la population on voit
que c'est une stratégie qui est
extrêmement risquée mais qui a été
gagnante après qu'est-ce qui va se
passer encore dans deux ans l'Amérique a
pas fini de nous surprendre la
population est extrêmement
de moins en moins réconciliables alors
est-ce que là avec en courant
républicain on peut traditionnel qui va
revenir dans leur rang avec des
politiciens qui sont plus habitués à ce
système de politique américain qui est
quand même dans la base est quand même
la politique du compromis est-ce que ça
va produire ses effets est-ce que la
menace la démocratie est en jeu qui a
été mise en avant par Joe Biden a été a
été elle a été efficace cette fois-ci
comme a été efficace la question de
l'avortement
parce qu'on s'est dit l'avortement au
mois de juin effectivement lors de la
décision de la Cour suprême ça
effectivement contribue à resserrement
très nette dans les sondages une
remontée des démocrates les esprits
s'échauffent et notamment le vote
féminin s'inquiète et puis on a eu le
sentiment juste avant le vote que ça
s'était dissipé au profit de questions
plus concrètes comme l'inflation la
hausse du coût de la vie aujourd'hui
c'est une préoccupation très forte vous
l'avez senti vous devez être une partie
de l'Amérique alors les sondages
disaient que 14 15% simplement des
électeurs au moment des meeters était
concernés par la question de
l'avortement on a vu que en fait ce
n'était pas le cas notamment dans les
états où les questions de préservation
de la vente du droit à l'avortement
était posée lors de ces mineurs donc on
voit que finalement l'avortement mais
probablement certaines libertés
publiques restent finalement un marqueur
très très fort pour certains Américains
qui ne veulent pas qu'on est à leur
dictée un certain nombre de choses
mais malgré tout la question de
l'inflation était majeure ça a vraiment
majeur tous les tout le monde vous en
parlait alors est-ce que les politiques
mises en place là encore par Joe Biden
en matière de lutte contre l'inflation
en matière de réindustrialisation du
pays vont porter leurs effets et
permettront aux démocrates de
j'allais dire de continuer à avancer
mais il est certain que les démocrates
là eux ce qu'ils ont dit c'est on nous a
sous-estimé
peut-être mais dans le ressenti mais qui
n'est juste un ressenti de reporter sur
le terrain j'avais le sentiment que les
choses étaient moins simples que ça
qu'on avait un petit peu sauvé le bateau
démocrate et sauver la démocratie
américaine mais que beaucoup de choses
étaient en jeu et que aujourd'hui que
les portes sont ouvertes chez les
républicains pour quelque chose de
beaucoup plus radical ça peut s'avérer
une victoire à la Pyrrhus pour les
démocrates tout dépend évidemment de qui
est désigné côté démocrate Jo Biden
a-t-il raison justement d'interpréter
ces résultats comme un encouragement à
se représenter alors il a dit qu'il se
prononcerait dans l'année qui vient mais
c'est certain que il posait la question
déjà un peu avant l'émetteur c'est il a
placé ses meetums en disant c'est pas un
référendum sur ma personne etc et tout
mais il se voit effectivement et là il
est renforcé dans cette idée là comme un
défenseur de la démocratie la question
s'il se représente pas tout de suite
c'est que bon de toute façon il faut il
faut laisser déjà le temps de ces
résoudre
pour l'instant personne n'énerge côté
démocrate on parle du gouv ce genre de
Californie qui est une des étoiles
montantes du parc nous sommes
des transports aujourd'hui mais sont-ils
sont-ils suffisamment forts aujourd'hui
dans le parti et après la question des
primaires oblige toujours les candidats
soit ce droitisé soit se gauchiser et
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui a été le
problème des démocrates jusqu'à présent
avec les démocrates qui ont aussi
toujours fait des campagnes finalement
très communautaires très sur les
questions sociétales avec une partie de
l'électorat qu'ils doivent reconquérir
Joe Biden avait dit qu'il serait le
président qui allait réconcilier
l'Amérique avec
la classe moyenne le problème c'est que
cette classe moyenne elle s'y retrouve
toujours pas parce que ce qu'elle veut
d'abord c'est l'économie donc si Joe
Biden gagne son pari économique avec le
plan de relance et avec les mesures
qu'il a prises notamment par la
récréation aux États-Unis d'industrie
américaine souhaite une très grande
partie de la population qui qui qui veut
se sentir autonome là dessus notamment
en matière de microprocesseur si cela
produit ses effets là effectivement Joe
Biden va avoir une autoroute devant lui
maintenant c'est un homme âgé et un
parti qui a besoin de se reconstruire
merci beaucoup Claude Guibal c'était on
va plus loin exceptionnellement avec
Claude comme unique invité à son retour
donc des États-Unis les élections du
monde à la couvert pour nos confrères de
France Inter merci encore on se retrouve
dans moins de 3 minutes pour un nouveau
journal d'en parler direct on ira faire
le point notamment du côté de la Pologne
ou deux missiles russes sont semble-t-il
tomber aujourd'hui
[Musique]